le second trailer de star wars 9 est
disponible et bon sens quand l'attendu
suis là comme d'habitude les amis on se
retrouve pour analyser ce trailer et wau
je trouve qu'il ya des choses à dire
mais tout d'abord n'oubliez pas que ce
n'est qu'un trailer
ils savent très bien jouer avec nous et
preuve rien qu'avec les chevaliers de
rennes confirmé dans ce neuvième et
dernier opus mais absent du trailer star
wars nous réserve encore bien des
surprises
tout d'abord j'aimerais réagir sur la
partie où nous voyons des passages
importants de chaque star wars
tout ceci est montré pour accentuer une
chose bien précises nous sommes à la fin
de la saga
le neuvième opus est le dernier d'une
lignée de films qui dure depuis bientôt
quarante deux années maintenant mais pas
seulement
ce passage certains accentuer la phrase
de l'udc que nous avions déjà entendu
dans le premier trailer mylan et de
générations vivent sans toi ce neuvième
opus va clairement se tourner autour de
ré présenté dans le trailer comme l'élu
ultime des jedi soit la dernière
néanmoins luc nous le rappelle également
this is your fights et on combat mille
générations de jedi vivent dans ray de
part son apprentissage et sa maîtrise de
la force mais c'est à elle de choisir
comment va se terminer l'histoire
doit-elle se battre doit-elle retrouver
ses véritables origines doit-elle rester
dans le côté lumineux
cette phrase prononcée depuis deux
trailer nous indique très clairement
qu'il ya un côté personnel à tout ça
l'udc aura fait tout ce qu'il a en son
pouvoir pour faire de ré la dernière des
jedi mais tout dépend d'elle et de ses
choix
après sept minutes de nostalgie nous
arrivons enfin aux nouvelles images ray
est accompagné de ses deux célèbres
acolytes ainsi que de chouilly et c3po
ces derniers semblent faire face à la
résistance qui s'est reformée suite aux
actions de l'udc dans l'épisode 8
l'étincelle qui va mettre le premier
ordre en cendres c'est encore plus
symbolisé par la présence de l'eia et de
son sourire mais il y a quelque chose
qui pose question ares semble leader de
son groupe et est absente de la
résistance avec finn et poke est
normalement très dévoué à l'eia
normalement ces derniers n'ont aucune
raison d'être en quête de quelque chose
à part préparer la guerre face à kei
lorraine et c'est quelque chose qui me
pose question est-ce que palpatine s'est
manifesté et les ja aurait renvoyé les
protagonistes le retrouver très peu sûre
mais il se peut qu'il y est un lit
avec palpatine ou bien est ce que ray
aurait fait une découverte sérieuse sur
ses origines c'est une option à garder
en tête
nous continuons avec l'événement obvious
la guerre entre les résistants et le
premier ordre
toutes les forces semblent être réunies
pour un affrontement des plus épiques
puis nous arrivons à quelque chose
d'intéressant c3po semble corrompus ou
posséder comme le montrent ses yeux
rouges à l'écran ce dernier et voyageant
côtés de ray peaufine et chewbacca
il se pourrait que le groupe se soit
fait capturer durant leurs péripéties du
moins seulement c-3po et dieu sait
quelle catastrophe il pourrait causer
d'ailleurs j'aimerais souligner une
chose depuis le tout début c-3po et
r2-d2 sont présents et quoi de plus
symbolique que la mort d'un des deux
droïdes pour marquer la véritable fin de
la saga
ce serait quelque chose de très triste
mais qui pourrait sérieusement arrivé
bien qu'ils puissent être reconstruits
évidemment nous avons également la
présence d'une femme accompagnant fine
et d'après d'anciens lic un nouveau
personnage allait faire son apparition
une femme je pense sincèrement que ce
serait telle peut-être va-t-elle
remplacer rose mais je ne pense pas bref
nous arrivons enfin au moment le plus
intéressant et je vous demanderais
d'être des plus attentifs
nous faisons face à une règle qui
s'entraînent certainement grâce à luc
mais également aux manuscrits jedi
qu'elle a récupéré avant que yoda ne
brûle l'arbre mais le plus intrigant et
la technique elle est en train
d'employés rebbah lance son sabre et le
fait revenir c'est un détail
ultra important déjà je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit l'udc qui lui a pris cette
technique mais qu'elle l'aurait plus
appris dans les manuscrits certainement
ou peut-être seul de son côté mais ce
qui est très important à souligner est
que cette technique est comme une
signature celle de dark vador
alors je ne parlerai pas des jeux je ne
m'avancerai pas sur ce qui est canon ou
pas mais cette technique est seulement
employés par dark vador dans les films
c'est d'ailleurs l'origine et la
naissance de ce coup pour moi c'est
réellement un argument clé et je reste
sur ma position depuis le début nous
sommes sur un film tournant autour de ré
principalement est nommé l'ascension des
skywalker
cela veut tout dire et encore plus par
le biais de ce coup employés seulement
par dark vador à la base
cinématographiquement parlant si
seulement deux personnages ont utilisé
c'est qu'il doit y avoir un lien
les deux sinon pourquoi leur amener
trente ans plus tard dans ce nouvel opus
vous enchaînons maintenant avec un
combat ultime entre ray écailles
lorraine et dont la fiche promotionnelle
qui a été partagée fait référence le
bien contre le mal
réunis seul pour s'affronter malgré leur
connexion toujours d'actualité et enfin
nous arrivons la partie que vous
attendez tous palpatine est bien présent
et nous le savons depuis maintenant un
certain temps notre plus grande surprise
nous sommes face aux plus grands
fantasmes des fans ray du côté obscur
avec un double sabre laser comme dark
maul à l'époque on ne peut pas ne pas
être hype et en voyant ça alors voyons
ce que nous pouvons en tirer
je pense tout d'abord qu'il ne faut pas
trop s'emballer et je suis désolé de
vous dire ça déjà par rapport à ce qui
est mentionné par dark sidious
auparavant ton voyage touche à sa fin
que veut-il dire par là dire cette
réplique implique clairement qu'il veut
se débarrasser de l'arrêt que nous
connaissons c'est à dire qu'il veut la
tuer soit physiquement soit tué son côté
lumineux mais dans tous les cas cela
implique qu'il est contre elle
maintenant si nous regardons de plus
près nous semblons être clairement face
à une ré à moitié robotique dans sa
façon d'être de regarder et d'agiter son
sabre nous ne sommes clairement pas face
à l'arrêt que nous connaissons si nous
regardons bien ses traits du côté obscur
semble être face à quelqu'un comme nous
pouvons le voir sur le bord de l'écran
et je suppose très fortement qu'il
s'agit de la véritable ray est ce que
ray serait face à un double opposé
d'elle-même pour savoir quelle est sa
véritable place dans l'histoire comme on
a pu nous le montrer dans l'épisode 8
dans la caverne miroir néanmoins les
paroles de palpatine auparavant
coordonne parfaitement avec la scène et
peuvent également nous laisser croire
qu'il s'agirait d'une fausse serait
incarnée par dark sidious néanmoins seul
ray et du coup dark maul sont ceux qui
utilisent des bâtons ou en l'occurrence
un double sabre et au vu de commencer
très du côté obscur le tiens cela me
rappelle très clairement l'arrêt de
l'épisode 7 avec son grand bâton le
mystère est donc permis et c'est à vous
de me dire si vous aimeriez 1,3 théorie
sur star wars neuf dans les jours à
venir
j'espère en tout cas que la vidéo vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus et à vous abonner
à la chaîne on se retrouve très
prochainement pour de nouvelles vidéos
et j'espère sur star wars que le liner
ce soit avec vous cet argot
[Musique]